the horrible conclusion which had been
gradually intruding itself upon my
confused and reluctant mind was now an
awful certainty I was lost completely
hopelessly lost in the vast and
labyrinthine recesses of the mammoth
cave turn as I might in no direction
could my straining vision seize on any
object capable of serving as a guidepost
to set me on the outward path that
Nevermore should I behold the Blessed
light of day or scan the pleasant hills
and dales of the beautiful world outside
my reason could no longer entertain the
slightest unbelief hope had departed yet
indoctrinated as I was by a life of
philosophical study I derive no small
measure of satisfaction from my
unimpassioned demeanor for although I
had frequently read of the wild frenzies
into which were thrown the victims of
similar situations I experienced none of
these but stood quiet as soon as I
clearly realized the loss of my bearings
nor did the thought that I had probably
wandered beyond the utmost limits of an
ordinary search caused me to abandon my
composure even for a moment if I must
die I reflected then was this terrible
yet majestic cavern is welcomed a
Sepulcher as that which any churchyard
might afford a conception which carried
with it more of tranquillity that of
despair
starving would prove my ultimate fate of
this I was certain some I knew had gone
mad under circumstances such as these
but I felt that this end would not be
mine
my disaster was the result of no fault
save my own since unknown to the guide I
had separated myself from the regular
party of sightseers and wandering for
over an hour and forbidden avenues of
the cave had found myself unable to
retrace the devious windings which I had
pursued since forsaking my companions
already my torch had begun to expire
soon I would be enveloped by the total
and almost palpable blackness of the
bowels of the earth as I stood in the
waning unsteady light I idly wondered
over the exact circumstances of my
coming end
I remember the accounts which I had
heard of the colony of consumptives who
taking their residents in this gigantic
grotto to find health from the
apparently salubrious air the
underground world with its steady
uniform temperature pure air and
peaceful quiet had found instead death
and strange and ghastly form I had seen
the sad remains of their ill-made
cottages as I passed them by with a
party and had wondered what unnatural
influence along sojourn and this immense
and silent cavern would exert upon one
as healthy and vigorous as I now I
grimly told myself my opportunity for
settling this point had arrived provided
that want of food should not bring me
too speedy a departure from this life as
the last fitful rays of my torch faded
into obscurity I resolved to leave no
stone unturned no possible means of
escape neglected so summoning all the
powers possessed by my lungs I set up a
series of loud shoutings and the vain
hope of attracting the attention of the
guide by my clamor yet as I called I
believed in my heart that my cries were
to no purpose and that my voice
magnified and reflected by the
numberless ramparts of the black maze
about me fell upon no ears saved my own
all at once however my attention was
fixed with a start as I fancied that I
heard the sound of soft approaching
steps on the rocky floor of the cavern
was my deliverance about to be
accomplished so soon had been all my
horrible apprehensions bent for naught
and was the guide having marked my
unwarranted absence from the party
following my course and seeking me out
in this limestone labyrinth
while these joyful queries arose in my
brain I was on the point of renewing my
cries in order that my discovery might
come the sooner when in an instant my
delight was turned to horror as I
listened for my ever acute ear now
sharpened an even greater degree by the
complete silence of the cave bore to my
benumbed understanding the unexpected
and dreadful knowledge that these
footfalls were not like those of any
man in the unearthly stillness of this
subterranean region the tread of the
booted guide would have sounded like a
series of sharp and incisive blows these
impacts were soft and stealthy as of the
pause of some feline besides when I
listened carefully
I seemed to trace the falls of four
instead of two feet I was now convinced
that I had by my own cries aroused and
attracted some wild beasts perhaps a
mountain lion which had accidentally
strayed within the cave perhaps I
considered the Almighty had chosen for
me a swifter and more merciful death
than that of hunger yet the instinct of
self-preservation never wholly dormant
was stirred in my breasts and though
escape from the oncoming peril might but
spare me for a sterner and more
lingering end I determined nevertheless
to part with my life at as high a price
as I could command strange as it may
seem my mind conceived of no intent upon
the part of the visitor Saves out of
hostility accordingly I became very
quiet in the hope that the unknown
beasts would in the absence of a guiding
sound lose its direction as had I and
thus passed me by but this hope was not
destined for realization for the strange
footfalls steadily advanced the animal
evidently having obtained my scent which
in an atmosphere so absolutely free from
all distracting influences as is that of
the cave could doubtless be followed at
great distance seeing therefore that I
must be armed for defense against an
uncanny and unseen attack in the dark i
groped about me the largest of the
fragments of rock which were strewn upon
all parts of the floor of the cavern in
the vicinity and grasping one in each
hand for immediate use awaited with
resignation the inevitable result
meanwhile the hideous patterning of the
paws drew near certainly the conduct of
the creature was exceedingly strange
most of the time the tread seemed to be
that of a quadruped head walking with a
singular lack of unison betwixt hide
than for feet yet at brief and
infrequent intervals I fancied that but
two feet were engaged in the process of
locomotion I wondered what species of
animal was to confront me it
must I thought be some unfortunate beast
who had paid for its curiosity to
investigate one of the entrances of the
fearful grotto with a life long
confinement in its interminable recesses
it doubtless obtained his food the
eyeless fish
bats and rats of the cave as well as
some of the ordinary fish that are
wafted in at every freshen of Green
River which communicates in some occult
manner with the waters of the cave I
occupied my terrible vigil with
grotesque conjectures of what alteration
cave life might have brought in the
physical structure of the beast
remembering the awful appearances
ascribed by local tradition to the
consumptives who had died after long
residence in the cave then I remembered
with a start that even should I succeed
in felling my antagonist I should never
behold its form as my torch had long
since been extinct and I was entirely
unprovided with matches the tension on
my brain now became frightful my
disordered fancy conjured up hideous and
fearsome shapes from the sinister
darkness that surrounded me and that
actually seemed to press upon my body
nearer nearer the dreadful footfalls
approached it seemed that I must give
vent to a piercing scream yet had I been
sufficiently irresolute to attempt such
a thing my voice could scarce have
responded I was petrified rooted to the
spot I doubted if my right arm would
allow me to hurl its missile at the
oncoming thing when the crucial moment
should arrive now the steady pat-pat of
the steps was close at hand now very
close I could hear the labored breathing
of the animal and terror struck as I was
I realized that it must have come from a
considerable distance and was
correspondingly fatigued suddenly the
spell broke my right hand guided by my
ever trustworthy sense of hearing
through with full force the sharp angled
bit of limestone which it contained
toward that point in the darkness from
which emanated the breathing and
pattering and wonderful to relate it
nearly reached its goal for I heard the
thing jump landing at a distance away
where it seemed to pause
having readjusted my aim i discharged my
second missile this time most
effectively for with a flood of joy I
listened as the creature fell in what
sounded like a complete collapse and
evidently remained prone and unmoving
almost overpowered by the great relief
which rushed over me I reeled back
against the wall
the breathing continued in heavy gasping
inhalations and expirations once I
realized that I had no more than wounded
the creature and now all desire to
examine the things ceased at last
something allied to groundless
superstitious fear had entered my brain
and I did not approach the body nor did
I continue to cast stones at it in order
to complete the extinction of its life
instead I ran at full speed in what was
as nearly as I could estimate in my
frenzied condition the direction from
which I had come suddenly I heard a
sound or rather a regular succession of
sounds in another instant they had
resolved themselves into a series of
sharp metallic clicks this time there
was no doubt it was the guide and then I
shouted yelled screamed even shrieked
with joy as I beheld in the vaulted
arches above the faintin glimmering of
full gence which I knew to be the
reflected light of an approaching torch
I ran to meet the flare and before I
could completely understand what had
occurred was lying upon the ground at
the feet of the guide embracing his
boots and gibbering despite my boasted
reserve in a most meaningless and
idiotic manner pouring out my terrible
story and at the same time overwhelming
my auditor with protestations of
gratitude at length I awoke to something
like my normal consciousness the guide
had noted my absence upon the arrival of
the party at the entrance of the cave
and had from his own intuitive sense of
direction proceeded to make a thorough
canvass of by passages just ahead of
where he had last spoken to me locating
my whereabouts after a quest of about
four hours by the time he had related
this to me
I am Bouldin by his torch in his company
began to reflect upon the strange beast
which I had wounded but a short distance
back in the darkness and suggested that
we ascertained by the flashlights aid
what manner of creature was my victim
accordingly I retraced my steps this
time with a courage
born of companionship to the scene of my
terrible experience
soon we described a white object upon
the floor an object whiter even than the
gleaming limestone itself cautiously
advancing we gave vent to a simultaneous
ejaculation of wonderment for of all the
unnatural monsters either of us had in
our lifetimes beheld this was in
surpassing degree the strangest it
appeared to be an anthropoid ape of
large proportions escaped perhaps from
some itinerant menagerie its hair was
snow-white a thing due no doubt to the
bleaching action of a long existence
within the inky confines of the cave but
it was also surprisingly thin being
indeed largely absent safe on the head
where it was of such length and
abundance that it fell over the
shoulders and considerable profusion the
face was turned away from us as the
creature lay almost directly upon it the
inclination of the limbs was very
singular explaining however the
alternation and their use which I had
before noted whereby the bees to use
sometimes all for and on other occasions
but to for its progress from the tips of
the fingers or toes long rat like claws
extended the hands or feet were not
prehensile a fact that I ascribed to
that long residence in the cave which as
I before mentioned seemed evident from
the all-pervading and almost unearthly
whiteness so characteristic of the whole
anatomy no tail seemed to be present the
respiration had now grown very feeble
and the guide had drawn his pistol with
the evident intent of dispatching the
creature when a sudden sound emitted by
the latter caused the weapon to fall
unused the sound was of a nature
difficult to describe it was not like
the normal note of any known species of
simian and I wonder if this unnatural
quality were not the result of a
long-continued and complete silence
broken by the sensations produced by the
advent of the light a thing which the
Beast could not have seen since its
first entrance into the cave the sound
which I might feebly attempt to classify
as a kind of deep tone chattering was
faintly continued all at once a fleeting
spasm of energy seemed to pass through
the frame of the Beast the pause went
through a convulsive motion and the
limbs contracted with a jerk the white
body rolled over
so that its face was turned in our
direction for a moment I was so struck
with horror at the eyes thus revealed
that I noted nothing else
they were black those eyes deep jetty
black in hideous contrast to the snow
white hair in flesh like those of other
cave denizens they were deeply sunken in
their orbits and were entirely destitute
a virus as I looked more closely I saw
that they were set in the face less
prognathous than that of the average ape
and infinitely less hairy the nose was
quite distinct as we gazed upon the
uncanny sight presented to our vision
the thick lips opened and several sounds
issued from them after which the thing
relaxed in death the guide clutched my
coat sleeve and trembled so violently
that the light shook fitfully casting
weird moving shadows on the walls
I made no motion but stood rigidly still
my horrified eyes fixed upon the floor
ahead
the fear left and wonder awe compassion
and reverence succeeded in its place for
the sounds uttered by the stricken
figure that lay stretched out on the
limestone had told us the awesome truth
the creature I had killed the strange
beast of the unfathomed cave was or had
at one time been a man I have never
heard an even approximately adequate
explanation of the horror at Martin's
Beach despite the large number of
witnesses no two accounts agree and the
testimony taken by local authorities
contains the most amazing discrepancies
perhaps this haziness is natural in view
of the unheard of character of the
horror itself the almost paralytic
terror of all who saw it and the efforts
made by the fashionable Wavecrest in to
hush it up after the publicity created
by Professor a Hans article our hypnotic
powers confined to recognize humanity
against all these obstacles I am
striving to present a coherent version
for I beheld the hideous occurrence and
believed it should be known in view of
the appalling possibilities that
suggests mertens Beach is once more
popular as a watering place but I
shudder when I think of it indeed I
cannot look at the ocean at all now
without shuttering fate is not always
without a sense of drama and climax
hence the terrible happening of August 8
1922 swiftly followed a period of minor
and agreeably wonder fraud excitement at
Martins beach on May 17th the crew of
the fishing smack alma Gloucester under
Captain James P ORN killed after a
battle of nearly forty hours a marine
monster whose size and aspects produced
the greatest possible stir in scientific
circles and cause certain boston
naturalist to take every precaution for
its taxidermic preservation the object
was some fifty feet in length of roughly
cylindrical shape and about ten feet in
diameter it was unmistakably a guild
fish in its major affiliations but with
certain curious modifications such as
rudimentary forelegs and six toed feet
in place of pectoral fins which prompted
the widest speculation it's
extraordinary mouth it's thick and scaly
hide and its single deep set I were
wonder scarcely less remarkable than its
colossal dimensions and when the
naturalist pronounced it an infant
organism which could not have been
hatched more than a few days public
interest mounted to extraordinary
heights captain oren with typical yankee
shrewdness obtained a vessel large
enough to hold the object in its hull
and arranged for the exhibition of his
prize with judicious carpentry he
prepared what amounted to an excellent
marine museum and sailing south to the
wealthy resort district of martin's
beach anchored at the hotel wharf and
reap the harvest of admission fees the
intrinsic marvelousness of the object
and the importance which it clearly bore
in the minds of many scientific visitors
from near and far combined to make it
the seasoned sensation
that it was absolutely unique unique to
a scientifically revolutionary degree
was well understood The Naturalist had
shown plainly that it radically differs
from this similarly immense fish caught
off the Florida coast that while it was
obviously an inhabitant of almost
incredible depths perhaps thousands of
feet it's brain and principal organs
indicated a development started lingly
vast and out of all proportion to
anything hitherto associated with the
fish tribe on the morning of July 20th
the sensation was increased by the loss
of the vessel and it's strange treasure
in the storm of the preceding night it
had broken from its moorings and
vanished forever from the sight of man
carrying with it the guard who had slept
aboard
despite the threatening weather captain
ORN backed by extensive scientific
interests and aided by large members of
fishing boats from Gloucester made a
thorough and exhaustive searching cruise
but with no results other than the
prompting of interest in conversation by
August 7th hope was abandoned and
captain Oran had returned to the wave
crest in to wind up his business affairs
at Martins beach and confer with certain
of the scientific men who remain there
the horror came on August 8th it was in
the twilight when grey sea birds hovered
low near the shore and a rising moon
began to make a glittering path across
the waters the scene is important to
remember for every impression counts on
the beach were several strollers and a
few late bathers stragglers from the
distant cottage colony that rose
modestly on a green hill to the north or
from the adjacent cliff perched in who's
imposing towers proclaimed its
allegiance to wealth and grandeur well
within viewing distance was another set
of spectators the loungers on the inn's
lantern lighted veranda who appeared to
be enjoying the dance music from this
sumptuous ballroom inside these
spectators who included captain oren and
his group of scientific confreres join
the beach group before the horror
progressed far as did many more from the
inn certainly there was no lack of
witnesses confused though their stories
be with fear and doubt of what they saw
there is no exact record at the time the
thing began although a majority say that
the fairly round moon was about a foot
above the low-lying vapors of The
Horizon they mentioned the moon because
what they saw seemed subtly connected
with it a sort of stealthy deliberate
menacing ripple which rolled in from the
far skyline along the shimmering lane of
reflected moonbeams yet which seemed to
subside before it reached the shore many
did not notice this Ripple until
reminded by later events but it seems to
have been very market differing and
heightened motion from the normal waves
around it some called it cunning and
calculating and as it died away craftily
by the black reef so far out there
suddenly came belching up out of the
glitter streaked Brian a cry of death a
scream of anguish and despair that moved
pity even while it mocked it first to
respond to the cry were the two
lifeguards then on duty sturdy fellows
in white bathing attire with their
calling proclaimed in large red letters
across their chests accustomed as they
were to rescue work and to the screams
of the drowning they could find nothing
familiar in the unearthly ovulation yet
with a trained sense of duty they
ignored the strangeness and proceeded to
follow their usual course hastily
seizing an air cushion which with its
attached coil of rope lay always at hand
one of them ran swiftly along the shore
to the scene of the gathering crowd
whence after whirling it about to gain
momentum he flung the hollow disc far
out in the direction from which the
sound had come as the cushion
disappeared in the waves the crowd
curiously awaited a sight of the hapless
being whose distress had been so great
eager to see the rescue made by the
massive rope but that rescue was soon
acknowledged to be no Swift and easy
matter for pull as they might on the
rope the two muscular guards could not
move the object at the other end instead
they found that object pulling with
equal or even greater force in the very
opposite direction till in a few seconds
they were dragged off their feet and
into the water by the strange power
which had seized on the proffered life
preserver
one of them recovering himself called
immediately for help from the crowd on
the shore to whom he flung the remaining
coil of rope and in a moment the guards
were seconded by all the hardy or men
among whom captain Oran was foremost
more than a dozen strong hands were now
tugging desperately at the stout line
yet wholly without a veil hard as they
tugged the strange force at the other
end tugged harder and since neither side
relaxed for an instant the Rope became
rigid as steel with the enormous strain
the struggling participants as well as
the spectators were by this time
consumed with curiosity as to the nature
of the force in the sea the idea of a
drowning man had long been dismissed and
hints of whales submarines monsters and
demons now passed freely around where
humanity had first led the rescuers
wonder kept them at their task and they
hold with a grim determination to
uncover the mystery it being decided at
last that a whale must have swallowed
the air-cushion captain Oran as a
natural leader shouted to those on shore
that a boat must be obtained in order to
approach harpoon and land at the unseen
Leviathan several men at once prepared
to scatter in quest of a suitable craft
while others came to supplant the
captain at the straining rope since his
place was logically with whatever boat
party might be formed his own idea of
the situation was very broad and by no
means limited to whales since he had to
do with a monster so much stranger he
wondered what might be the acts and
manifestations of an adult of the
species of which the 50-foot creature
had been the merest infant and now there
developed with appalling suddenness the
crucial fact which changed the entire
scene from one of wonder to one of
horror and dazed with fright the
assembled band of toilers and onlookers
captain oren turning to leave his post
at the rope found his hands held in
their place with unaccountable strength
and in a moment he realized that he was
unable to let go of the rope
his plate was instantly divined and as
each companion tested his own situation
the same condition was encountered the
fact could not be denied every struggler
was irresistibly held in some mysterious
bondage to the hempen line which was
slowly hideously and relentlessly
pulling them out to sea
speechless horror ensued a horror in
which the spectators were petrified to
utter inaction and mental chaos their
complete demoralization as reflected in
the conflicting accounts they give and
the sheepish excuses they offer for
their seemingly callous inertia I was
one of them and know even the strugglers
after a few frantic screams and futile
groans succumbed to the paralyzing
influence and kept silent and fatalistic
in the face of unknown powers there they
stood in the pallid moonlight blindly
pulling against a spectral doom and
swaying monotonous ly backward and
forward as the water rose first to their
knees then to their hips the moon went
partly under a cloud and in the half
light the line of swaying men resembled
some sinister and gigantic centipede
writhing in the clutch of a terrible
creeping death harder and harder grew
the rope as the tug in both directions
increased and the Strand swelled with
the undisturbed soaking of the rising
waves slowly the tide advanced till the
sands so lately peopled by laughing
children and whispering lovers were now
swallowed by the inexorable flow the
herd of panic-stricken Watchers surged
blindly backward as the water crept
above their feet while the frightful
line of strugglers swayed hideously on
half submerged and now at a substantial
distance from their audience silence was
complete the crowd having gained a
huddling place beyond reach of the tide
stared in mute fascination without
offering a word of advice or
encouragement or attempting any kind of
assistance there was in the air a
nightmare fear of impending evils such
as the world had never before known
minutes seemed lengthen into hours and
still that human snake of swaying torsos
was seen about the fast rising tide
rhythmically it undulated slowly
horribly with the seal of doom upon it
thicker clouds now passed over the
ascending moon and the glittering path
on the waters faded nearly out very
dimly ride the serpentine line of
nodding heads with now and then the
livid face of a backward glancing victim
gleaming pale in the darkness faster and
faster gathered the clouds till at
length they're angry rifts shot down
sharp tongues of febrile flame thunders
rolled softly at first yet soon
increasing to a deafening maddening
intensity then came a culminating crash
a shock whose reverberations seemed to
shake land and sea alike and on its
heels a cloud burst whose drenching
violence overpowered the darkened world
as if the heavens themselves had opened
to pour forth of in dictum torrent the
spectators instinctively acting despite
the absence of conscious and coherent
thought
now retreated up the cliff steps to the
hotel veranda rumors had reached the
guests inside so that the refugees found
a state of Terror nearly equal to their
own I think a few frightened words were
uttered but cannot be sure some who were
staying at the end retired in terror to
their rooms
while others remain to watch the fast
sinking victims as the line of bobbing
heads showed above the mounting waves
and the fitful lightning flashes I
recall thinking of those heads and the
bulging eyes they must contain eyes that
might well reflect all the fright panic
and delirium of a malignant universe all
the sorrows sin and misery blasted hopes
and unfulfilled desires fear loathing
and anguish of the ages since time is
beginning eyes alight with all the soul
racking pain of eternally blazing
infernos and as I gazed out beyond the
heads my fancy conjured up still another
eye
a single eye equally a light yet with a
purpose so revolting to my brain that
the vision soon passed held in the
clutches of an unknown vise the line of
the Damned dragged on their silent
screams and unuttered prayers known only
to the demons of the black
waves and the night wind there now burst
from the infuriate skies such a mad
cataclysm of satanic sound that even the
former crash seemed dwarfed amidst a
blinding glare of descending fire the
voice of heaven resounded with the
blasphemies of hell and the mingled
agony of all the loss to reverberate it
in one apocalyptic planet rending peal
of cyclope and din it was the end of the
storm for with uncanny suddenness the
rain ceased and the moon once more cast
her pallid beams on a strangely quieted
sea there was no line of bobbing heads
now the waters were calm and deserted
and broken only by the fading ripples of
what seemed to be a whirlpool far out in
the path of moonlight once the strange
cry at first come but as I looked along
that treacherous Lane of silvery Sheen
with fancy fevered and senses over rot
there trickled upon my ears from some
abysmal sunken waste the faint and
sinister echoes of a laugh
darlin pricked her finger with the
needle and winced immediately stuck the
finger in her mouth and tasted blood for
pete's sake misty stand still stop
fussing over the girl darlin said her
husband Warren from across the room
honestly you'll give her a case of hives
darlin didn't give him the satisfaction
of a glance you stay out of this you
might not care if our daughter goes to
the cotillion lookin like something a
hound dragged in but I do mother
misty side from atop the Ottoman and you
hush too she tugged on the sash she'd
been altering blowing a wisp of sweaty
hair off her forehead lurid misty you
must have gained 10 pounds since we
bought this dress what have you been
eating food mother misty shifted her
weight to the other foot can I please go
now not until I finish this darlin
pulled the sash up widening the folds
pinning it back near the zipper she
reached for the sewing kit down by her
foot it was hot in the room despite the
air conditioning the giant picture
windows displayed a scene of visibly
wavering humidity where even the palm
trees stood motionless their fronds
drooping and listless gripping the
needle between her teeth Starlin poked a
strand of silky lavender thread through
the eye then grimly set to work on the
sash she wouldn't kid herself she knew
moving the sash wasn't going to
completely camouflage the little roll of
fat misty had sprouted in the past three
weeks she glanced up at the mirror
opposite no not perfect but better than
before when the pale purple satin was
stretched so taut that the dent of the
girl's bellybutton showed
even with misty fidgeting and scratching
it herself darlin managed to get the
sash sewn on flawlessly no one would be
able to tell how the original dress had
looked and darlin felt a tiny surge of
pride at the thought there she said now
run along and take it off before you get
it all sweaty
finally misty leaped down from the
Ottoman her mouse brown hair sticking to
her bare shoulders she stomped into the
adjoining bathroom and darlin heard
sounds of rustling taffeta and muffled
cursing you shouldn't be so hard on her
sugar Warren was smoking a cigar one leg
crossed over the other he was gazing out
the window his bald head Sheen with
perspiration darlings anger bubbled up
from her stomach and into the space
behind her lips but she let nothing
escape she simply glared at him her
mouth a tight line misty emerged from
the bathroom intruding on her parents
heavy silence
she was now clad in a faded pair of
jeans with holes at the knees and a
baggy gray t-shirt that had bleached
spots across the breasts daddy's right
you know she said grabbing a comb off
her mother's dresser and yanking it
through her hair I just want you to be
the prettiest girl there darlin said
trying to keep the edge out of her voice
figuring she'd get further by flattering
rather than nagging the Radin boys are
going to be there you know maybe you'll
catch the eye of one of them mother
misty rolled her eyes what century is
this for Christ's sake don't swear and
all I want is for you to be taken care
of darling you're getting to the age
when you should be thinking about
getting married and the Radin boys are
very good people who says I have to
marry anybody
darlings honey tones finally succumb to
the vinegar I say no daughter if mine's
gonna end up an old maid Jesus mother
daddy listen to her
Missy crossed her arms and scowled she
just means the best for you kitten
Warren said puffing on his cigar he
smiled at his daughter affectionately if
a little distantly run along now
misty blue I'm a kiss and flounced out
of the room glancing once over her broad
shoulder and making a face at her mother
when she had gone darlin gave a harsh
sigh Warren you could be a bit more
supportive she began gathering up
pursuing things throwing them back in
their box with far more force than was
necessary I mean look at the girl she's
getting fat her face is starting to
break out she hasn't washed her hair and
I don't know how long she can't go to
the cotillion like that she'll be the
laughingstock I won't be able to show my
face that's all you're really worried
about isn't it Warren's voice was very
calm he washed his cigar smoke swirling
lazily toward the ceiling showing your
face don't start with me warranty
Young's blood the third you know damn
well how Missy reflects on you as well
as on me you could at least pretend to
care a little bit for your daughter's
sake Misty's fine the way she is sugar
he stubbed out his cigar in the ashtray
next to his chair then got to his feet
with a grunt clearly signaling that he
was finished with the conversation
Warren don't you walk out on this but he
already was waving his hand as if to
dismiss her his leather slippers
whispering on the carpet
he didn't slam the door but - darlin it
sounded as though he had she stood in
the middle of the room for a long moment
her teeth clenching and unclenching
without her being completely aware of it
the air-conditioning hummed overhead a
lulling sound darlin went to the windows
and stared out at the withering heat
feeling abandoned and put upon dusk was
beginning to fall and lights across the
water were winking on like fireflies
coming out to swarm damn him she thought
mr. Warren T bigshot lawyer Young's
blood the bloody third miss T most
certainly wasn't fine the way she was no
matter what Big Shot Young's blood had
to say on the matter
and while he may have been content to
let misty be a fat pimply slob who would
never get a man
Berlin had other plans let warrants it
on his widening ass and smoked his
cigars she thought balling her fists and
scrutinizing her reflection in the
darkening window misty needed fixing
fast and our Lynne aimed to do something
about it
it had been just before dawn when she'd
set out she hadn't told Warren where she
was going but she rarely did and he
never asked misty was staying over at a
friend's house it was now nearing 8:30
and the temperature was already hovering
near 90 the air conditioning in the car
was going full blast but even so the
heat pressed down sunlight battered in
through the windows making darlin feel
like an egg in a microwave she hadn't
eaten any breakfast though she'd pulled
in at a rest stop for coffee a few miles
back the warm liquid now sloshed in her
stomach seemingly eating the lining away
at last the exit for Garson loomed ahead
and she flipped on her blinker coasting
off the main highway with it's late
rush-hour traffic
thick knots of cypress trees began to
close in as soon as she had cleared the
ramp and merged onto the sun-baked
two-lane that led to Garson and then it
was another ten miles of nothing the
trees pressing in as they're jostling
for a look clogging the air in her lungs
finally she passed the dispirited gas
station that marked the Garson city
limit she cruised past it noting its
dust caked windows and the cigarette
signs with ghosts of prices on them
pockmarked by bullet holes nothing ever
changed here she thought as she drove
into the town proper steering carefully
on the only paved street
this was the town where she'd been born
the town where she had walked barefoot
to a clapboard schoolhouse taking care
not to stumble into the muddy swamps
that edge the houses on three sides this
was a town where toothless old men drove
hogs from their pitiful farms on market
days slapping the animals flanks with
willow switches making them squeal so
loud that they could be heard in every
house in the village it was a place
where no one bothered to make fun of the
kids with the ragged secondhand clothing
or the facial deformities because all
the kids had one or the other and
times both darlin past the dirt road
where her old house had stood but she
resisted turning down it the house
itself is no longer there anyway it had
been demolished in Hurricane Ivan along
with half the town
her parents were gone too claimed by
alcoholism in her father's case and a
12-gauge shotgun and her mother's darlin
remembered them both their faces briefly
emerging from the tar pit of her distant
memory but she felt nothing at all they
might as well have been strangers the
town looked nearly deserted naturally
most of the residents would be indoors
on such a scorching day she noticed a
few grain box fans propped up in
screened windows blades turning
languidly pushing the hot air around the
interiors as she passed the general
store she saw two very old men and one
young one sitting on the wooden porch
rocking back and forth in their chairs
smoking pipes and watching her car go by
through slitted milky eyes she only
passed one other vehicle a pickup truck
that had probably once been read before
the Sun and mud had taken its toll the
truck bed was packed with hay and atop
the piles were a few bedraggled goats
that stared dumbly out at the scrolling
landscape once the tattered town center
was behind her
darlin kept driving until the tiny
concrete block houses and improvised
wooden shacks became farther and farther
apart before disappearing altogether
when the cypress trees closed in again
she drove some more it was funny how she
still remembered her way even after all
these years it was almost as though the
memory was imprinted instinctual there
was no sound at all except for the roar
of the air-conditioning and the lazy
buzz of the cicadas outside another mile
and the road began to disintegrate its
faded asphalt gouged out in enormous
pits that were brimming with stinking
brown water she vividly recalled the
first time she had come out here she'd
been 16 and had ridden her bike she'd
had to steer through the minefield of
potholes had faltered once and sprawled
headlong into one of the puddles her
mother had been furious when she got
home shrieking over the state of her
clothes
grilling her about where she'd been to
get so filthy darlin had stood resolute
under her mother's tirade smiling
secretly inwardly it wasn't long
afterwards that the blare of the shotgun
had silenced the woman shrieking forever
darlin carefully maneuvered the car off
the road parking it on what pass for a
shoulder feeling the tyres sinking a few
inches into the mud it would be useless
to drive any farther she knew for the
road ahead was unpaved and usually
washed out with the summer rains but the
place she was going was only a short
walk from here she fetched her first-aid
kit from the trunk and set out the
second time darlin had come had been
just past her 18th birthday she almost
laughed at the thought that misty was
now the same age she had been but there
had been no cotillion for darl in no
fancy dress and expensive dyed shoes no
rich folks suns and crisp tuxedos
smiling at her with their pricy
orthodontia after her parent's death she
had simply stayed on in the little house
by herself dropping out of high school
and taking a full-time job at the feed
store to support herself she'd had
boyfriends mostly local boys big
strapping things who always seemed to
have teeth in the process of rotting
down to Nub's who never seemed to have
much going on under the rafters despite
that Darlene had genuinely liked some of
them and even let some of them touch her
just over the panties though she was no
[ __ ] but even back then she knew she was
destined for something better
the second time she had come out here
she had driven an old car that she had
paid for with her own money it had more
rust than paint and had a muffler that
scraped gaily against the road throwing
sparks in all directions but it was hers
she had walked through the woods in her
knock-off designer jeans and her
gold-tone hoop earrings feeling like she
owned the place and just as cheeky as
you please she had stepped right up and
asked for a miracle a knight in shining
armor to take her away from this place
forever
darlin couldn't help smiling darkly to
herself as she picked her way through
the MA strewn undergrowth Warren wasn't
exactly at night but he was rich and
relatively educated and their meeting
had seemed the stuff of fantasy his car
had broken down not far from Garson and
he'd hiked into town to use the
telephone at the feed store where she
worked
yesterday's fury at Warren had softened
a little and she thought of him now with
a touch more charitable Ness yes he was
stubborn and uninterested most of the
time and he drank too much and was far
too flirtatious for his own good but he
had certainly done what she had wished
for and had shown her a way of life that
she had never dared to imagine for
herself for that she had to admit she
was grateful to him the heat made the
way ahead of her seem hazy and unreal
the mist rose off the stagnant ponds and
made the tree-trunks look like black
paint slashes against the whiteness the
smell was just as she remembered green
and thick and rotten but with a
seductive musky quality that tickled the
back of her throat something splashed
just off to her left and she jumped but
then a bird chattered amiably and dived
past her into the trees and her heart
slowed again the tree cover grew denser
and denser of her head and before long
it almost seemed as though dusk had
arrived several hours early her feet
ached in their impractical gold skimmers
and her white blouse and slacks were so
saturated with sweat that they were
practically transparent her dark bangs
clung to her powdered forehead it
occurred to her that the cabin might be
gone that the storm might have swept it
away her brow furrowed and she squinted
into the verdant dimness at first she
could see nothing but shifting shadows
but after a moment something shimmered
into existence like a mirage in the
desert it was still here the cabin
looked almost exactly as she remembered
other than being slightly more weathered
the board's more riddled with termites
annals everyone in Garson had called it
a cabin but that was a misnomer
there were only four rough walls that
hung together in some semblance of
structure the little shack had no bottom
the slats and logs making up the house
barely propped up by the mud and swamp
water beneath no one had ever ventured
inside but Darlan had sometimes pictured
it in her mind
I the windowless wall is crawling with
slugs and black flies the suckin gurgles
of the swamp like liquid breaths and the
steamy confined space she suddenly felt
very cold
despite the midday Sun filtering through
the branches darlin moved toward the
cabin glancing left and right
her ears poised to pick up this latest
sound she noticed that silence had
fallen over the woods and she grew
colder still remembering those other two
times she had come the birds and insects
had all ceased their trilling and even
the breeze seemed to have stilled
rendering all the leaves as motionless
as marble the only noise was the gentle
lapping of the swamp upon the mudbank a
soft organic sound that soon grew as
loud as an ocean in her ears about a
hundred yards in front of the cabin
almost concealed by the undergrowth was
a flat gray stone roughly four feet
across
darlin was looking for it and so didn't
stumble when its edge suddenly appeared
from the carpet of leaves and moss she
knelt down feeling her blouse sticking
to her back and armpits and brushed the
worst of the growth off the stone its
surface was smooth and worn with white
gouges scattered like strange cuneiform
letters dark stains were ground into
most of the gashes but darlin tried not
to look too closely looking around again
her skin crawling with the sensation of
being watched
darlin reached into the pocket of her
slacks and drew out the small Swiss Army
knife she'd taken from the kitchen
drawer that morning some of the
implements were modeled and rusty but
the knife blade looked passively sharp
with its tip she tapped her chin
thinking she'd have to cut something
that wouldn't be noticed or that could
be explained away fairly easily the
first time she'd come she'd given the
end of her left little finger the second
time it had been a small chunk of her
earlobe no one but Warren had ever
noticed either injury and when she told
him she'd done them in her high school
shop class
he hadn't batted an eye
at last Arlen slipped off one of her
gold shoes teetering she placed one foot
up on the gray stone planting the still
shod foot in the mushy undergrowth for
balance the cold that it seized her
earlier was gone and the breathless heat
was back as she leaned over her knee
knife in hand her sweat spattered the
rock with thick fat droplets the blade
was poised over her toe and she made
herself breathed slowly trying to calm
the racing of her heart sweat dripped
into her eyes and she wiped it away with
a trembling hand feeling her mascara
beginning to run the woods around her
grew quieter as if waiting even the
sound of the swamp water was no longer
audible gripping the knife handle in her
slick palm darlin gritted her teeth and
sliced whimpering but otherwise keeping
the pain inside she had to cut four
times to completely sever the end of the
little toe it bled far more than she
expected and as she stared down at the
widening puddle on the rock her vision
swim and she had to fight to keep her
balance the tiny pink fragment of flesh
floated in the sea of red like a nipple
on a painted breast darlin felt nausea
accompanying the faintness but she
shoved both away grasping tightly at the
knife handle as though it was her only
lifeline after a few moments she had
gathered herself and she slid her
bleeding foot from the rock letting it
settle into the cool muddy leaves the
pain immediately subsided that she could
still feel the blood pumping freely in
time with her hammer and heartbeat
she dug her toes and deeper stanching
the flow then pulled it out quickly
opening her first-aid kit and washing
the wound wrapping it fickler in gauze
watching as the crimson bloomed onto the
white fabric now before the blood on the
rock had dried Darlene crouched down and
placed her hands alongside her offering
of flesh she closed her eyes feeling the
heat in the forest around her like a
living presence huge and wild and not
necessarily friendly it was listening
she knew waiting her eyes still closed
she told it silently what she wanted
when her litany was over she opened her
eyes very slowly watching the dark
greenery coming into focus around her
the air seemed lighter now and the sound
of the water had returned heaving and
sucking at the banks she felt as though
she had awakened from a dream
disoriented but somehow reborn when the
birds and insects resumed their chorus
darlin stood and slid her dirty foot
back into her gold shoe carefully so as
not to dislodge the bandage she gazed
once more at the little cabin before her
which seemed to have subtly shifted
Thank You mr. scales she murmured then
turned and limped out of the clearing
trying to ignore the enormous rolling
splash that followed her pronouncement
the girl was radiant her glossy hair
falling in perfect dark ringlets around
her heart-shaped face her figure tiny
and pert in its lavender satin sheath
her skin even and creamy and glowing all
traces of the fat roll in the pimples
she displayed earlier in the week had
miraculously vanished
darlin felt her eyes filling with tears
but before they could spill over she
glanced around the room making sure that
everyone assembled kept their gazes
fixed on her beautiful baby and on no
one else and yes she saw everyone was
staring expressions rapturous even the
Raiden boys Kyle and Justin resplendent
in their matching white tuxedos were
standing by the buffet table with their
mouths hanging open
darlin smiled the elixir of triumph
surging through her veins mr. scales
always came through when misty alighted
from the staircase and relinquished her
father's arm she was practically
trampled by the mobs of boys coming
toward her their hands outstretched
begging for the first dance
darlin took another surreptitious look
around and noticed all of the other
girls in the room lovely in their own
right of course but no match for misty
not tonight
staring daggers at her daughter there's
hand arms folded tightly across their
breasts she smirked
at last the crowd around misty dispersed
she had chosen her dance partner
it wasn't Kyle or Justin Darlene saw but
an even more handsome boy who she
recognized as the only son of dr. Avery
Thomas a prominent heart surgeon in town
darlin silently applauded her daughter's
excellent selection then watched with
amusement as the rejected boys began
dancing with the other girls
the second choices the boys were clearly
disappointed and looked over their
partner's shoulders at misty whenever
they thought they could get away with it
the songs changed and there was another
mini melee when it all shook down misty
was dancing with the older Raiden boy
Kyle she was smiling brightly at him and
batting her eyelashes her golden
flawless skin rippled like silk under
the muted light from the chandeliers
Warren sidled up to darlin and slipped
an arm around her waist see sugar there
was absolutely nothing to worry about he
sounded as though he might have already
down to champagne or three but darlin
just kissed his cheek she didn't want
anything to spoil her mood tonight
an hour passed in a mere moment and
darlin had a pleasant champagne buzz
going herself when there was a break in
the music Darlene had lost track of
misty for a while but now she spotted
her pulling away from her latest partner
this boy was handsome but he looked
older and a little hard
darlin didn't recognize him misty
drifted toward her mother smiling like
an angel darlin held her hands out and
swept her daughter into her embrace are
you having a good time darling
yes mother it's the best night of my
life she looked almost unreal her skin
flushed with excitement and exertion her
dark eyes syrupy and deep her voice was
breathy I just wanted to say that I'm
sorry for being such a pain the other
day I feel really bad you were right
about everything
darlin glanced sidelong at Warren who
stood a few feet away not even listening
she focused her attention back on her
daughter I always want what's best for
you misty she said snagging another
champagne with the waiter slithered by
with the tray she gestured with the
glass toward the dance floor where the
unfamiliar boy was waiting his hands and
the pockets of his trousers his chin
tilted back ever so slightly giving him
an air of arrogance
he was obviously staring at misty and
obviously not caring who noticed him
doing it who's the mystery man you've
been dancing with Misty's eyes sparkled
and she leaned close to her mother
conspiratorial a his name's Alec isn't
he adorable
darlin squinted through the thickets of
shimmering satin and taffeta adorable
wasn't exactly a word that she would
have used to describe Alec he was indeed
a good-looking man tall and broad with a
definite aura of physical strength
almost of menace his hair was dark but
patterned with lighter streaks at odd
intervals like a tortoiseshell his face
was wide as was his mouth giving the
illusion that he wore a permanent
sardonic grin darlin couldn't tell what
color his eyes were from this distance
but they looked strange pale and intense
her brow furrowed who were his parents
misty shrugged he said he was an orphan
but don't worry he seems to have plenty
of money she glanced back and gave an
almost imperceptible wave der Linde
squared her shoulders meaning to ask how
misty could know the boy had money but
she decided to let it pass
well don't monopolize the boy how were
kyle and Justin they're nice young men I
hear yeah they were nice
Misty's tone was dreamy barely there and
she glanced backward again her whole
body's seeming to pull toward Alex
tractor-beam gaze there was a crackle
from the sound system and then the music
started up again a slow song that had
been all over the radio that summer and
misty cocked her ear toward it like a
bird hearing the call of its mate I'll
talk to you later she said and drifted
away the lavender silk of her skirt
rustling like a shared secret misty but
the girl was already gone holding out
her arms toward Alec being swept into
his large slightly intimidating embrace
there was something almost feral in the
way he held her his big hands claw-like
and possessive on the peach glow expanse
of her back
darlings stomach knotted and she looked
to Warren for support but he had moved
farther away and was draping himself
drunkenly across the shoulders of dr.
Thomas's young saucily blonde wife
darlin seized but made no motion to rein
him in
let him have it later at home when she
wouldn't cause an embarrassing scene
misty was the important issue at present
darlin said her mostly drained glass on
a table against the wall and threaded
her way through the crowd swaying a
little on her feet but otherwise
controlled it was difficult to get a
good look at misty and alak they had
moved to the middle of the dance floor
and darlin could only catch glimpses of
them through the shifting obstructions
at the other couples but she could see
enough to discern that they were dancing
far too close for propriety their bodies
pressed together as though striving to
become one
their lips poised and shining and only
inches apart every now and then Alec
would lean his large head close and
whisper something in Misty's ear she
would look at him then with her
twinkling eyes her expression fervid in
serious darling bit her lip and tapped
her foot on the parquet floor with every
minute that passed she was liking the
situation less and less the slow song
finally ended and the couples broke up
some wandering off to pair up with
others some retreating to the tables for
refreshments darlin hoped she would spot
misty milling through the crowd
searching for a new partner
but she wasn't terribly surprised to see
that she and Alec were walking languidly
hand-in-hand toward the French doors at
the far end of the ballroom the ones
that opened onto the patio Derlin felt
the last of the champagne buzz hurtling
into a livid sobriety as she watched
them she found she no longer cared what
indiscretions Warren was perpetrating
and she did not look around for him to
back her up her prime objective from
this moment was to stop misty wandering
out onto the lowly patio with his
handsome nobody who had so audaciously
staked his claim
darlin thought at the sight of his huge
hands on Misty's silky vulnerable back
and the memory drove her forward adding
fuel to the engine of her mounting rage
the couple was at the door now and Alec
swept it open in an ostentatious gesture
of chivalry standing aside to let misty
hover through the door atop her lavender
finery he followed then very close
behind her and pulled the door shut
quietly but definitively Darlins pace
quickened her fury now all-consuming she
pushed through the swirling crowds
everything moving in slow motion around
her through the fairy lights and
laughter
the door ahead of her loomed huge in
solitary blocking out all else in her
vision it seemed to take an eternity to
reach it as though it was a door in a
dream finally she clasped the latch she
didn't open the door not right away
first she stood very still her ear
pressed against the frosted glass for a
few moments she heard nothing more than
the lapping of the lake against the
wooden deck supports but then she
thought she could make out other sounds
secretive giggles and intimate murmuring
her blood boiled silently she turned her
hand on the door latch restraining the
urge to throw the door wide and confront
the couple she pushed at the glass
opening it just a crack peering through
she could just see them on the far end
of the patio their backs partially
facing her they were standing very close
closer than they had when they were
dancing and Darlene's temper flared up
another few notches Alec had his face
nuzzled into Misty's neck looking like a
vampire draining blood from the jugular
and Misty for her part seemed to be
enjoying the sensation immensely her
head thrown back her eyes closed her
back wanton Leigh arched dearl in noting
their preoccupation risked opening the
door a little further spilling muted
yellow light onto the deck in a long
thin parallelogram now misty had begun
to push her hips up into Alec's body
gyrating a little and her hands searched
out his tortoiseshell hair clasping
through the strands as though seeking a
handhold for her desperate need
Alec's motions at her neck grew more
heated and his fingers began inching
their way down from her shoulders toward
her high round breasts wrapped in their
shiny covering of pale violet satin darl
in unable to stand anymore flung the
door wide
several things happened at once Misty's
hands seemed to come away from Alex head
but with the hair still attached Darlan
squinted hard in the dimness thinking
she might still be drunk after all
unsure of what she was seeing before
Missy had quite realized what had
happened Alec had reared back and the
twinkling lights from the windows shone
down upon a hideous deformity a head
that appeared coarse mache
discolored darlin gasped and at the
small sound Alec whipped his face toward
her his eyes were like no human eyes she
had ever seen inside and the bewitching
light from the chandeliers perhaps no
one had noticed but here in the darkness
the filmy glowing eyes of a nocturnal
creature were unmistakable yellow and
reptilian with deep black slits for
pupils they narrowed as they watched our
Lynn misty too frightened to move
shivered against the railing of the
patio wiping her hands obsessively on
her skirt as though to rid herself of a
skin borne plague she had dropped the
wig at her feet and it lay there the
breeze ruffling through it almost
playfully Alex still held her tightly
and though she struggled some against
his grip it was clear that her strength
was no match for his don't hurt her
darlin risked two steps out onto the
patio then pushed the door closed behind
her immediately muffling the sounds of
gaiety from inside she wanted help
needed it but she didn't like the
thought of what the creature might do to
misty if everyone at the party came
rushing out to see what was going on she
held out her hands a universal gesture
of surrender
Alex simply stood and looked at her his
chest rising and falling in regular
rhythm darlin noticed that the scaly
skin upon his head extended down his
neck and disappeared into the color of
his tuxedo shirt the image of what he
might look like under his clothes made
her shudder mother misty was imploring
pleading with her eyes Derlin realized
that her daughter still looked
unnaturally beautiful even in her
distress the knot in her stomach
tightened mr. scales as soon as she said
the name the air surrounding them seemed
to change become cold and hushed a
pocket of isolation
darlin had noticed Misty's eyes widen
silently questioning how her mother knew
the identity of this creature that held
her but darlin kept her gaze fixed on
Alec what more do you want from me
she asked taking a few more steps
forward what can I give you to release
her Alec tilted his head the gesture of
a weary predator his lips parted
frog-like but no sound emerged in
Darlins head though a voice rattled in a
hollow croak the voice of the swamps in
the town where she had been born there
is nothing the voice said as Alec stood
there with his crocodilian mouth open
and smiling its sardonic smile three
favors I have granted you woman the
first two times I took what you gave I
did what you asked even though sometimes
you asked for evil things but you were
too greedy this time I did what you
asked but the offering you left was not
enough I came to take more darlin felt
as though she was a million miles away
from anywhere frozen in time the secret
green smell of her childhood forming a
dimension all its own misty had started
to cry a pitiful keening into the wind
take me instead then darlin didn't know
she was going to speak the words until
she said them but once they were out she
knew that this was the way things were
supposed to go he seemed to be
considering his golden eyes glittering
in the darkness perhaps something can be
arranged he croaked silently with his
free hand which looked more like a claw
now than ever he gestured to darlin to
come toward him let misty come to me
first
she said not moving mr. scales shook his
head come here or I will pull her down
in the water with me take her back to
the swamps he grinned wider with his
horrible mouth she will make him lovely
wife for a lonely old man like me
darlings mind grew crowded with images
of her beautiful baby pressed into the
mud under the belly of this nightmare
creature she moved toward him quickly
holding her hands out like a lifeline
misty misty reached out for her mother
her face contorted with anguish and
confusion but still as angelic as ever
help me she said
darlin had just touched her daughter's
fingers when she felt mr. scales
powerful arm encircling her waist she
screamed but the sound was pitiful
carried away by the strange cold breeze
don't fight woman the voice croaked in
her head your end will be quit no darlin
struggled hard filling the creature's
sandpaper skin against her cheek and
neck she threw her head back seeing the
lights from inside the shadowed forms
moving behind the French doors
Warren was there he must be missing them
by now surely he would come out soon to
see where they had gone no one will come
for you mr. scales whispered into her
brain as though he was reading her
thoughts your daughter is blameless so
she will be spared to live with me
forever and my beautiful small but you
he made a strange bellowing sound a
sound of disgust no one knew what you
wished about your parents but I knew
Darlene began hitting him in the chest
with her fists but it felt like he was
wearing armor why did you grant my wish
then she shrieked why you asked I do he
croaked simply it is my purse with that
the muscles in his arms tightened until
Darlene felt trapped by bands of iron
she tried to scream again but she could
get no air her lungs seemed filled with
swamp water green and black and muddy
her feet left the floor of the deck and
she was falling falling backwards then
there was a splash and it was cold so
very cold misty screamed and beat her
arms against the water but then even
that sound became muted as Darlene was
dragged under the water of the lake the
lake that led to the swamps the swamps
where she had been born the water
cradled her like a lover and mr. scales
wrapped his powerful arms around her
body and the world went silent and green
and then it went black